so when joey helped me try to get my uh
internet and sim card and originally i
got internet and
uh a sim card with the the same company
um turned out the sim card just didn't
work on my phone yeah and
uh because they were like oh we don't
sell this model of phone in japan
um so in in europe i don't know if it's
the same as the us
but you can basically buy sim cards
anywhere and they'll work with every
phone yeah like it doesn't matter what
it is you just put it in it works
yeah um but yeah apparently that's not
the case in japan because of course it
isn't
found out that japan is the only country
on earth that uses a very specific type
of uh
like uh bandwidth or whatever it is that
the phone lines use
so a lot of phones don't work in japan
because japan was like no no we're gonna
be different and it's like
of course you watch man of course
everything's got to be different
and that's why like getting a phone here
is [ __ ] hell yeah and that's why like
sim cards are so expensive i think
recently they did something about
uh they're going to change it because i
think the government is like it's
getting out of hand
like the prices of phone phone carriers
here ridiculous i mean i'm paying more
for my phone than i am my internet
yeah yeah yeah i'm paying 90 bucks a
month for my [ __ ] phone yeah and
that's
that doesn't include that doesn't
include the phone that's
i bought the phone myself i think i'm
paying like 70 bucks a month and when i
get like it's
in gigs of data yeah it's insane it's
like what is this [ __ ] this [ __ ] is
stupid
this is way too much for [ __ ] it's okay
it's good but i mean it's good
it's good but it's [ __ ] but it's [ __ ]
that they're charging me this much yeah
i paid
i paid 15 in the uk for what i was 10
pounds
uh for what i was getting yeah i i think
i paid like 20 pounds a month in the uk
that's expensive for like unlimited data
yeah it's ridiculous
and when in the uk when they when they
say unlimited data they actually mean
unlimited data i've never been throttled
in my data in the uk at all the speeds
are fantastic here don't get me wrong
but
speeds are great not not to the point
where we're talking 100
a month speed come on yeah yeah yeah
it's more than my internet bill you have
a bit come on
yeah it's a joke i mean it works really
well but i just yeah
and that's why like a lot of people i
know don't even bother getting sim cards
because you have to sit there for like
four hours
talking to them asking answering dumb
questions and they try and sell you a
ton of stuff like uh because i think aki
doesn't even use her
no she still has an american thing and
just pays for pocket
wi-fi because she's like she looked at
like all of her friends getting
you know the sim cards and whatnot she's
like i'm not going through that [ __ ]
[ __ ] that it's hell but i just don't
want to have to charge a [ __ ] uh
portable wi-fi thing all the time oh
yeah yeah
having a japanese number does help
sometimes with things like a lot of
forms
require you to have japanese numbers for
some reason yeah blind
so i wasn't that convenient where's my
japanese [ __ ] fluent boyfriend who
translates and does everything for me
huh
yeah no so if i were her i would totally
do the same thing yeah to be honest yeah
honestly like the only reason i wanted a
phone was because i didn't want to carry
an extra thing with my phone just to get
one
right you're not carrying like a person
with you all the time yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah
that's just annoying exactly yeah um but
yeah i know several people who just have
pocket wi-fi here just because it's they
don't want to go through the trouble of
switching their phones or well i mean
raynor still has pocket wi-fi and she's
been living here for like
half a minute insane do you even have
pocket wifi isn't popular in like europe
i don't think in
the us it's like not mainstream i never
really heard of it until i moved it
exists but like it's
it's not like it's not nearly common as
you see here because clearly they've
made a market where
the phone the cell phone carriers are so
[ __ ] awful that there's a
whole industry about avoiding them yeah
look
it it's ridiculous and the price of
these pocket wi-fi's are much cheaper
than the self
much cheaper yeah it's just stupid yeah
like i legitimately dread whenever i
have to sort out like the smallest thing
within like my living situation here in
japan because like if they they
i don't know how they all somehow always
turn like a five to fifteen minute
meeting to like
a [ __ ] hour long
deal i'm waiting for the day where you
know how sometimes when you're on a
website you have to change your email
they'll be like please come in person to
change your email and it would take like
four hours and it's like i could have
done this online